[Musique]
le 10 août 1919
magellan s'embarque pour une des plus
belles aventures humaines le premier
tour du monde
il part avec lui un jeune homme un jeune
italien un chroniqueur il se nomme
antonio pigasse est sa devise
il n'y a pas de roses sans épines il ya
écrit dans une de ses chroniques en
voyage ça ne se vit pas de l'intérieur
ça se pense ça se mûrit mais surtout ça
se vit alors cet homme à 18 ans il m'a
bouleversé je l'avais croisé lors d'un
cours d'histoire en rhéto et comme lui
je voulais voyager comme lui je voulais
comprendre passer de l'autre côté du
miroir
durant mon enfance en algérie
j'ai très vite acquis une conscience
politique à cette époque l'algérie était
un des pays clés du clan des non-alignés
je me souviens que lorsqu'il y avait des
voyages d'état la ville était placardé
de portraits et moi souvent bloqué dans
les embouteillages à l'arrière d'un bus
qui me ramenait à la maison je rêvais de
rencontrer ses hommes je me souviens
dans voyage en 1973 celui de fidel
castro à la maison on a souvent vu cette
photo où on voyait mon père lui serrer
la main lui l'ingénieur qui était venu
en algérie pour construire les premières
tracteur algérien
et puis la visite en 1975 la visite
historique du premier président français
depuis l'indépendance c'était valéry
giscard d'estaing seul je ne savais pas
à cette époque là c'est que cet homme
que j'ai croisés à et les reports alors
que je rencontre je rapportais mon grand
père j'allais le croiser bien plus tard
rentrer en europe
je suis devenu un adolescent prêt à
m'embrasser pour des causes politiques
pour des combats j'ai fait partie d'une
organisation qui s'appelait le mjp et là
on a lutté pour pas mal de choses pour
par exemple on a lutté contre
l'apartheid contre les missiles en
europe mais le mjp c'était surtout une
organisation de chantier bénévole et ses
chantiers c'était l'initiation la
rencontre de l'autre
l'altérité en fait je me souviens qu'un
jour on m'a invité à participer à un
séminaire européen sur l'immigration
ce jour là j'ai rencontré une jeune
hollandaise qui me parle a pour la
première fois de fédéralisme européen
eh ben ça at il été tout de suite parce
que ce fédéralisme européen c'était les
arts la réalité sociale et politique à
laquelle moi je pouvais macro chez moi
le fils italien né en belgique qui avait
été éduqué dans les lycées français
d'algérie et qui avait eu des copains
roumains hongrois polonais tout de suite
j'ai milité tout de suite je voulais
comprendre si le fédéralisme européen
était bien ce qui nous permettrait de
garder l'apec sur notre continent
l'impossibilité de faire la guerre comme
disait cannes khl au je me suis bien
rendu compte que il n'y avait pas de
roses sans épines
mais au départ c'était excitant j'ai
rencontré des intellectuels j'ai
rencontré des preuves du nifff qui
militait bénévolement pour cette europe
en construction
ils n'ont enseigner instruits et puis
des hommes politiques des femmes
politiques qui m'ont fasciné je me
souviens de borislav geremek un des
leader fondateur de solidarnosc que je
l'avais rencontrée lors de d'une
université d'été
et puis vint le temps il faut choisir
j'avais étudié le cinéma à la télé
j'adorais la politique
finalement j'ai choisi le cinéma la tv
tout en gardant cette curiosité pour la
cause politique
et moi je voulais voir de mes yeux voir
comment ces hommes et ces femmes
agissent et comment ils mettaient les
mains dans le cambouis alors j'ai
participé à des dizaines de réunions
partout dans le monde des conseils des
sommets à bruxelles
mais à paris à londres à stockholm à
helsinki mais aussi à hong kong à
washington à new york à jakarta à pékin
très vite l'envi de faire du
documentaire est née je voulais devenir
le chroniqueur de cette europe en
construction un peu comme pigalle fait
je voulais être en immersion passer de
l'autre côté du miroir je voulais aller
là où les journalistes ne voulait pas
aller et surtout je voulais poser un
geste cinématographique alors on tourne
europe clap
première 2002 des hommes et des femmes
politiques se rassemblent à bruxelles
pour rédiger la constitution européenne
il y à leur tête un homme
valéry giscard d'estaing
vous savez celui que j'avais rencontré à
l'aéroport à constantine quand j'avais
10 ans lui il voulait construire
l'histoire avec un grand h
et moi je voulais être le chroniqueur de
leur histoire un jour giscard dessin m'a
invité à clermont ferrand
chez lui j'ai eu droit à une longue
interview puis un repas dans un
restaurant deux étoiles
l'empathie naissait lors de mon retour
vers bruxelles dans l'avion le ciel
était blanc une tempête de neige
parsemé d'éclairs bleus était ce un
mauvais présage pour les conventionnels
cette convention c'était comme un
doctorat sur l'europe d'aujourd'hui et
demain
beaucoup de ces conventionnelle on les a
retrouvés à les postes clés dans les
années q si vert michel barnier monsieur
bré excite fra nce timerman vice
président de la commission john brunton
premières embrassades hors de l'union
européenne auprès des états unis et puis
la première première ministre danoise
mais ce sont des bruits de bottes ceux
de la deuxième guerre de l'irak qui
déviait le chemin de la convention
l'europe se fissurait
et les chefs d'état ont sifflé la fin de
la récréation
je me rendais compte que la politique
emmagasiné une partie de la violence
dans nos sociétés lors du dernier jour
de la convention
giuliano amato vice-président du
contexte vice président du conseil
italien me fit une dédicace à l'unique
auteur de la dette' heavy valorise paper
de cette constitution
j'étais content je gagnais mes galons de
chroniqueurs mais je n'allais pas
m'arrêter en si bon chemin alors europe
clap deuxième 2004 je décide de réaliser
un nouveau documentaire le portrait du
nouveau président de la commission qui
allait mettre en place la constitution
en juillet les chefs d'état devaient
choisir un nouveau président de la
commission dans mon for intérieur
j'avais pas favoris jean luc dehaene un
homme politique plus et qui avait été
vice président de la convention
je l'avais rencontré en juillet 2001 à
vilvorde
quand on y arrivait qu'il nous a ouvert
la porte on a été surpris il était en
tongs et lunettes du soleil et il
regardait une étape du tour de france
l'étape terminé on a parlé europe
et puis compromis en fait ce n'est pas
jean luc dehaene ketchup élu président
de la commission c'est josé manuel
barroso jose manuel barroso s'était ce
jeune premier ministre portugais qui
avait organisé en 2003 aux açores le
sommet des va-t-en-guerre de la deuxième
guerre de l'irak
il y avait bush blair as d'art et
barroso pour barroso ce poste de
président de la commission
c'était comme une récompense pour
services
rendus mais tout ne se passera pas comme
prévu le 25 mai 2005 un coup de tonnerre
résonne dans le ciel de bruxelles
laissant les français votent non à la
constitution
je me souviens ce soir-là d'être resté
seul dans un studio télé avec le
président barroso
j'étais avec mon caméraman je me suis
avancé je lui ai tendu un verre d'eau et
puis je lui dis un jour difficile et il
me répondit oui vous vous attendiez à sa
limite
il me dit pas ça pas ça de la part de la
france aujourd'hui les populismes ont
gagné moi je me rendais compte que le
fossé entre les hommes politiques et les
citoyens grandissait et que dès
maintenant l'europe
ouvrez un nouveau chapitre dans son
histoire celle de la déconstruction et
moi en tant que chroniqueur caméra au
poing j'étais prêt à ouvrir une nouvelle
page septembre 2005
je suis barroso direction pékin à
l'ordre du jour libéralisation du marché
du textile il a avec lui son commissaire
au commerce extérieur mme anne delson
arrivé à pékin avec le commissaire
mendelssohn nous nous rendons
directement dans la salle aura lieu les
négociations
je rentrais là où les journalistes ne
pouvaient pas rentrer dès qu'ils
arrivent mandelson dit abu pillay son
adversaire chinois j'aimerais que la
réunion se tienne en petit comité et
bauchi là il lui dit à l'ordre du jour
le textile rien que le textile
en fait j'étais surpris
c'était seuls les chinois qui fixait
l'ordre du jour après des heures de
négociations
il y à un accord boxill haye
emanuelson sortent de la salle
boxill haye a le sourire en coin avec
mon cameramen on observe et il dit d'un
air est venu ironique je ne devrais pas
sourire vous allez vous faire des
ennemis
les robes se fragiliser pierrette
ominetti une des responsables du
documentaire arte france à cette époque
là disait de moi
sergio on a l'impression qu'il ya une
petite souris caché dans le coin d'une
pièce qui est transparente avec toi on a
le sentiment de suivre l'histoire
contemporaine très contemporaine mois
j'accumulais les séquences de tournage
je façonnait mon regard de réalisateur
alors nouveau départ août 2010 direction
moscou
je suis barroso le président barroso et
le président sarkozy
direction la résidence du président
medvedev
quand j'arrive la résidence du président
medvedev et que je vais dans la tendre
devait avoir lieu la conférence de
presse je suis frappé par un détail il y
a des drapeaux français et puis il y a
des drapeaux russe
mais il n'y a pas de drapeaux européens
alors je décide de mener mon enquête de
manière naïve oublier le drapeau
européen
mais non les russes n'en veulent pas ils
veulent fomenter les différences entre
les européens les bons et les mauvais
élèves ceux avec qui on peut parler et
ceux qui sont les esclaves des
américains je me rendais compte que tous
les moyens étaient bons pour affaiblir
l'europe et tout était réglé dans les
moindres détails
mais ne pensez pas que les adversaires
étaient uniquement à l'extérieur de
l'union
il y en avait aussi à l'intérieur et un
s'appelait égoïsme national 2010 c'est
la crise il faut sauver la grèce et il
faut sauver l'euro les réunions de crise
se succèdent une à une et je suis là je
les observe
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour avec mon caméraman
on assiste à une rixe entre la ministre
des finances finlandaise et le ministre
des finances des finances grec
jutta urpilainen s'approche de béni
'sell-off' et lui dit tu m'avais promis
ces documents veut les est par essence
et documents je ne peux pas faire voter
le plan de sauvetage je ne peux pas
retourner dans mon parlement venizelos
tu réponds tu les auras aujourd'hui ou
demain
ne t'inquiètes pas j'ai les banques sous
mon contrôle et l de films mines et je
peux te faire confiance et lui
oui et pas seulement politiquement
à partir de ce jour là je décide de
quitter les salons de pouvoir l'europe
est considérée comme celle qui
démantèlent l'état providence les
citoyens ont le sentiment de payer pour
une crise
qu'ils n'ont pas enclenchée à athènes je
suis là je vois les citoyens grecs crier
leur colère
c'est ça la démocratie quel avenir pour
nos enfants dans les semaines qui
suivirent
j'ai eu une conversation avec un ami
journaliste et il me disait ah vous les
fédéralistes
vous êtes la libye du grand marche du
grand capital vous aident le cache sexe
des multinationales et moi de répondre
non nous sommes la condition pour la
paix sur notre continent
aujourd'hui j'ai façonné un autre regard
mon regard est plus incisif peut-être
plus critique
aujourd'hui je continue d'observer les
actes des politiques et de voir surtout
les conséquences sur les citoyens ou
même sur l'environnement des effet
papillon
aujourd'hui je me pose des questions sur
la survie politique de notre continent
mais peut-être en espoirs en mai 2020
les européens l'ofs
une nouvelle conférence sur l'avenir de
l'union un peu comme celle de 2002 mais
cette fois ci les citoyens tiendront la
peine le stylo ils ont ont droit
d'écrire le texte
alors malgré la tempête
j'ai décidé qu'il était peut-être temps
de nouveau de passer de l'autre côté du
miroir de nouveau être le chroniqueur
d'une europe en reconstruction
parce que l'europe c'est je pense la
plus belle aventure politique jamais
tenté alors on tourne europe clap
[Musique]